simulation theory is just the way that
modern people talk about basic religious
Concepts and in a world that doesn't
accept religion and so and the way we
talk about the magnets and the fields
and whatever but yeah we're talking
about Holiness and we're talking about
spiritual reality and so of course it's
the case that uh some people are are
Holier or two people and more attuned to
this but the thing is you can grow in
Holiness and you can also turn away from
the grace of God and when you say well
you can't give it to someone else that's
because it's about your relationship
with God it's not about your
relationship with some other dude I had
a guy tell me a story that he uh became
Christian because he was doing drugs he
was in the woods and then he woke up in
the morning strung out hungover went to
go take a leak and then all of a sudden
felt this booming voice from within his
own chest say what are you doing and it
freaked him out and then it said you are
wasting your life you have to stop this
you have to change and he didn't know
what it was so he went and sought
answers and then found you know holy men
who explained to him what this was what
it meant he got clean started the
business and lived a fulfilling life
with his friends and became very
responsible and he went from a strung
out drug addict wasting away into a
productive member of society after
having this profound moment and he said
to me I don't care if you don't believe
me it happened to me and I can never
give you that feeling but I assure you I
experienced it oh of course I was like
no I believe you it was a voice that
sounded like why Saul of Tarsus are you
persecuting me these things happen
people have those Road to Damascus
moments yeah and you know some and and
I'm sure the secular atheist types might
just say well he was on drugs he was
having a psychotic break or whatever and
I'll be like call it whatever you want
explain it however you want this person
had a experience where they felt
something that changed their life for
the better I I'm totally okay with that
I think sometimes your frontal lobe
clouds your your spiritual part of the
brain maybe because when it quiets when
you can go into Flow State and and dim
the activity in your frontal lobe is
when you really time starts to lose
meaning I think it can kind of happen
and there's so much activity like
stimulating the frontal lobe my name who
am I I exist in my frontal lobe without
that you're kind of part of it do you
wonder Ian though if you're if you're
confusing the physical for the
metaphysical like you're you're talking
about this as if your brain is
controlling everything as if the
physical world is controlling uh some
aspect of your metaphysical
understanding but what if those two
things are just occurring simultaneously
or if or if what if it's going in the
opposite direction so now we we say all
the time I had such an adrenaline rush
we don't say I got excited right we say
I had oh I got a dopamine hit instead of
I felt happy but why is the physical the
only meaningful thing when in fact the
physical world alone can't have any
meaning let me let me bridge this with
science people who do DMT and break
through the veil and then see some other
kind of entity Beyond this realm usually
demons well but maybe but we shouldn't
call them demons but why make that
assumption some of them may be demons
what if some of them are more holy or
something like well I got I actually had
a great interview there's a little bit
of a plug-in for my YouTube channel I
have this two-hour interview with a guy
who was a total psychonaut All In into
psychotropics and hallucinogens and he
he thinks they're demons but it's worth
if people want to go watch it's to our
conversation but yeah I'd be more
inclined to believe they were demons to
be honest but um at the same time a bit
more agnostic on whatever people
experience this whatever they could be
but the only reason I bring it up is
because if if it is true that multiple
people I mean hundreds of thousands of
people have experienced some kind of
consistent entity by taking this this
chemical than when you Ian like as you
were saying you you conflate the
metaphysical with the physical when you
experience these things it could be
something Beyond the Veil reaching into
yeah I think I focus on the physical a
lot because I feel like that's what I
can control in the in the process that
like it's like a radio tuner I can tune
it to the right frequency but I'm not
making the music happen
um so I say I'm just so evidence-based
so I'm looking at like but I think the
magnetic field it's like moving around
the magnetic field I I believe you can
but it's like if you have a magnet in
your hand and you're moving it
underneath underneath a piece of paper
with all these iron fragments on top of
the paper the iron's moving but are you
moving the iron or are you moving the
magnet you're moving the magnet the the
iron filings are just moving I think
you're I think you're still making the
same epistemological error though which
is you're you're saying that you're
evidence-based and so you want to ground
everything physically but the error here
is the idea that reality is
fundamentally physical which it
certainly is not the fact that we have
intelligible speech that the fact that
symbols have meaning that we it can
interpret and that we rely on it all it
tells you that the reality is
fundamentally metaphysical and there's
evidence
that's physical too yeah I got that I
got this because Ian you're a fan of
Incubus I love Incubus and Brandon Boyd
what's up dog and they have that song
where
um I don't know if it's which song it
has a Certain Shade of Green or
something like that where in the middle
of the song There's a recording of a guy
who says at the turn of the century
humans thought that what they could
touch smell see in here was reality but
since the initial publication of the
charged electro magnetic spectrum humans
have learned that what they can touch
smell see in here are less than is less
than one millionth of reality
so there you go it's a good that's a
good line actually from Incubus which is
a kind of a demon yeah when you talk
about it it literally is it literally
when you talk about physics what's
physical they used to think of solid
liquid and gas and then all of a sudden
at some point they realize oh plasma is
a fourth state of physical matter
there's more there's more physical stuff
than we realized and when you look at
Clouds of plasma moving around I don't
think they're intelligent but there
seems to be a sentience involved with
the way that plasma like it doesn't move
like a cloud in the air well you you
you're a physical thing and you are
sentient also but the sentience isn't
isn't from your that your Consciousness
your rationality is not from your
physical body that's you're just a clump
of cells in your physical body that your
your reason comes from your rationality
I'll put it this way we're we're uh
we're playing a video game
it's not a simulation it's a video game
and we are entities that exist beyond
the physical bodies but we are occupying
them to facilitate this simulated
experience in plasma clouds there's
these things called plasmon in the
center of plasma clouds and when they're
hit with photons with light it causes
the plasma Cloud to react so it's like
it's like information is being
transferred from light into plasma which
is then cooling down into gas and then
into liquid and then into solid but that
doesn't that doesn't have to be a
conscious process physical things react
to stimuli right where it seems like a
sentient process not necessarily
conscious but like if I if I threw let's
say I threw an explosive like those
people last night at Pitt if I threw an
explosive at that wall the wall would
react and there'd be a hole in the wall
or a dent in the wall but the Wall's not
conscious I think you're right I think
Consciousness is like is like living
organisms seem to have Consciousness not
necessarily organisms because it's going
to be carbon based but like living
things have Consciousness but unliving
things have sentience it seems like like
when they say God is I don't think God
is conscious I think it's sentient well
so God is consciousness right God is
reason uh uh but if we're talking about
sentience in the sense that uh one can
feel Sensations you know like a an
animal or even simpler organisms can
react to certain stimuli you know they
can feel pain say
um that's true and and when we talk
about Consciousness we're usually
talking about rational Consciousness so
we can discuss abstract things you know
we can talk about justice but an ape or
a or a plant can't talk about Justice
right I I think Ian desperately wants to
believe in God he does he does every
time I'm here I just think you're like
you're so close but you keep falling
into all this we're talking about a
different thing when we say God because
if there's a conscious God he's
for a personal relation ship with us as
individuals and if there's a God who's
not conscious but he's sentient somehow
no no but what I'm saying is the
questions Ian asks sound more like a
please make me understand totally yeah
totally I used to be agnostic and then I
saw the cosmic microwave background
radiation I was like okay I I'm evidence
guy that is evidence of God that is like
looks like a neural but everything is I
mean I remember I had this when I was an
atheist I was sitting out having a cigar
in my little front porch and I had this
tiny little house in in New York and I
had this dead rose bush what the thing
was all it wasn't like a beautiful thing
that I was looking at but I just I was
sitting there and I was looking at the
leaves and the complexity of the leaves
on on this dying rose bush and I thought
you know
there's got to be some logic here
there's got to be why is that so complex
why is that conveying meaning to me even
this totally quotidian thing and it
wasn't it wasn't the the biggest push in
my becoming a Christian and believing
that God exists but it was another piece
of evidence which is the the evidence of
meaning and intelligence is all around
us it's here it's even in the stupid
book genderqueer that Fibonacci Sequence
that golden ratio keeps showing up in
reality well yeah because there's a
structure to the universe there's a
logic and there's a math and we're only
like you're like wow the golden ratio is
everywhere but in reality it's just you
noticing a tiny little piece of the
logic of the universe that exists
sometimes I wonder if I'm looking
through the lens of the spiraling Galaxy
there's three types of galaxies there's
irregular galaxies which is like a star
cluster then they become a spiral galaxy
where it starts to spin then they form
up into a spheroid Galaxy and I feel
like we're in a transition towards the
spheroid but I wonder if because we're
in a spiral other things look like
they're spiraling so we're only seeing
the Fibonacci sequence from our
perception because we're wearing spiral
glass perhaps so I I will we'll dive
into the subject matter just because it
came up and I think it's a good
opportunity with having you here because
uh Sheamus will be back uh next week so
we're really excited for Sheamus
Coughlin of Freedom Tunes we'll be
hanging out Seamus is going to be the
one to actually get you Ian I I can
maybe push a little bit on the
Apologetics but Sheamus is a Shiite
wahhabi Catholic was an answer for
absolutely everything he is he's a very
but uh I wanna I wanna I wanna make this
point for those that haven't heard it
um because we briefly mentioned that
simulation theory is the language used
by you know how to describe it it's just
the way modern people talk about
religion because they don't know how to
talk about religion so it's it just
seems more relatable for people when I
when I was in Catholic school and we
were learning about science and we were
learning about uh energy and I was told
that you know to realize energy cannot
be created destroyed uh it can only be
changed energy is and always has been
and I was like it sounds very similar to
how you describe God or or the universe
or things like that it just sounds like
you you're talking about something
similar and they never really gave me a
good philosophical understanding of any
kind of similarities or what it could
possibly mean but as a kid who was nine
years old I certainly took that to heart
and considered maybe what they mean is
like maybe back when they wrote this
stuff when the Bible was being written
when people when holy men were studying
and coming with ideas they were they
were conveying their understanding of
the universe without our modern
sensibilities so that brings us to
simulation Theory
where you get people who are seemingly
atheists saying I kid you not a more
advanced entity than us created this
universe for a purpose with rules and
expects something from us and then I'm
like I can't tell if you're a holy man
or a stimulus are are you attack bro
from Silicon Valley or are you someone
trying to explain the rudimentary
religion to me the simulation language
that people use now if it if it
persuades anyone it's fine by me but
it's it's better even than the idea of
energy you you recognized a similarity
between something in the created world
and the creator of that world but the
the idea that God just is synonymous
with the world or that God it just is
the world and there's a little God left
over which is called penen theism that
is that is different from the Christian
idea and the monotheism and the way
things really are the simulation theory
is a better mapping of that because you
have God who is entirely self-sufficient
who does not need us who creates the
world in this act of Love out of nothing
and makes us in his own image that is in
the modern way we talk about it just
some geeky programmer who like makes us
now get this I often hear people say
something like well if God created the
universe who created God and it's just
like well hold on now you're ascribing
our physical limitations to something
that is beyond our physical limitations
but here's a better way to explain it
all
y'all have played The Sims I have all
four of them are the Sims smart enough
to comprehend this reality or existence
Sims aren't smart exactly but they do
their little thing they live in their
little Universe they don't have a degree
of Consciousness they are not smart we
that's us yeah we are the Sims we are
the very stupid bumbling around and then
we cannot comprehend what exists Beyond
do you believe when you think about
Destiny and free will do you think that
we're just destined to play a part in
this chemical reaction
I I think
the likely uh I wouldn't say I'm as
definitive as Michael but I believe
we're here for a reason I believe the
universe was created for a purpose I
believe that it's entirely possible the
universe is actually only 5 000 years
old and that is I'm not saying I believe
it hold on I'm saying it's possible if
you are someone who believes in
simulation Theory the idea being you've
played uh you play Grand Theft Auto oh
yeah that was the only video game as a
teenager that I played because it was
just so shocking not not let me I want
to point this out uh when you play Grand
Theft Auto you know there is no point in
that video game where people built
buildings yeah where our construction
crew came in and constructed a
skyscraper it just always has been and
the that Universe was created
specifically in the year 2013 or
whatever and it just came into existence
and so I find it fascinating that people
who believe in simulation Theory can't
understand the same argument from a
religious perspective that the Universe
was created five thousand years I don't
like that argument I used to think that
nothing existed unless I was perceiving
that everything was a wave of infinite
possibility outside of our perception
and my perception collapse reality and
this is just a simulation I'm
experiencing it was very egocentric it's
called solipsism and other people were
like Ian you freak I'm part of this too
like what's wrong where did you go
you're not the Ian I used to know and so
I think it it's possible that it's both
that and everyone's experiencing that
and but it because of that we're all it
is all real but we're also it's all a
wave of infinite possibility I mean it
is possible aren't those mutually
contradictory exactly yes yeah so they
can't simultaneously well they can't
contradictions can exist in nature
no what well like Quantum Computing
allows something to be a one and a zero
at the same moment
yes
that's true you're saying that there are
you're saying that there are
possibilities that can collapse down
into actualities that's the quantum the
physical person Quantum physical
perception of like the I don't know
double I don't want to misquote the
double slit experiment but things were
like electrons work as function as a
cloud until you put a perception on them
then they collapse into their where
they're at but you don't know where
they're gonna be at until you look yeah
but now but what you're suggesting is
now I'm always a little hesitant when
people bring up Quantum things because I
just find
you know physics is very hard and I I
because uh all of the quantum language
is so Fantastical people tend to turn
them to their own ideological or
theological purposes so I'm a little
cautious with it but is is are you
suggesting that scientists have
discovered a way to violate Aristotle's
law of non-contradiction uh I'm not
familiar with there which is the idea
that that mutually contradictory things
can't simultaneously exist well I kind
of like uh women's bathrooms and
transgenderism well I disagree because I
think someone could be a man and a trans
woman at the same time but not a female
correct they've given a female a trans
man but if they're still both in this
regard what we're currently what we if
assuming you believe all of the
companies that have claimed this Quantum
Computing is uh right so computers
operate with yes and no Gates ones and
zeros Quantum Computing allows the the
calculation to exist as a one and a zero
in the same space at the same time so
the calculations happen rapidly oh sure
sure so I I understand I understand the
not rapidly but instantaneous right
right no I understand that from the
perspective of rapidity but I don't
really understand and we're speaking in
language that is figurative even when we
talk about ones and zeros I don't really
understand what it means for these uh
contradictory things to be said another
contradiction so basically
contradictions right well let me let me
explain if uh let's let's say you want
to brute force a password right yeah
imagine it like you have uh an ant farm
yeah when you when you're looking
through the glass you can see all these
little paths and trails that go all the
way down in in little shapes like a maze
yeah if you were to try and send in one
drop of water at a time to navigate that
maze it gets blocked you do another up
it gets blocked that's brute forcing to
get to the bottom yeah Quantum Computing
would be yeah right water straight in
the top so the whole it goes and it
instantly gets you to the bottom and
gives you that access here's an example
of a contradiction a simple
contradiction like when you look at that
number what number do you see well I see
nine I see a six but you see us and
we're both right
well no we just we don't know which way
is the top of the paper I don't think
there is a top of the paper there is a
top of the paper but who's told who's
going to decide well I can tell you I've
got good evidence for it so let me
I'm pleased to say that I'm right about
what the number is uh because I can see
that the the paper was pulled from your
notebook now this way oh you're wrong
I'm wrong yes look where the margin on
the paper is okay um
if if I were more observant and more
scientific I would have noticed where
the margin was on the paper what did you
say you said nine you flip it yeah so
there it is the margins at the top six
yep it's the six listen I don't I'm a
modern person you were right it is a
nine from your perspective perspective
no I I unfortunately Tim was right and I
was wrong and you were right
but the reason is there there the paper
has a Direction objectively This what I
can know using my perception and using
my reason where the paper came from what
the orientation of the paper is and once
I know that I can know if this is a six
or a nine and Ian I'll be the bigger man
you were right so assume there was no
paper it was just outside in the
wilderness You Came Upon that symbol it
doesn't there's no relativism it just
your your perception is what it is no no
hold on let me let me let me answer this
for you Ian uh let me see the paper yeah
so the the way we deduced that this was
in fact a six and not a nine is first
Michael tried to point out the tear and
he assumed it came from this side of the
of the paper but you were holding it
upside down so you assumed it came this
way in fact Ian pulled it out from the
other side the margin is at the Top If
the margin was not there and we couldn't
determine what it was that doesn't mean
it is a six it is a nine it means we
don't have enough evidence to form the
correct conclusion but it is a six and
it is a nine no no both at once that's
the correct contradiction of reality
that can exist uh Ian I I disagree and
I'll explain if someone were to write a
password onto a piece of paper and they
wrote 666 and it was a square Post-It
note that with no sticky it was like a
square piece of paper and they dropped
it somewhere it was intended the
intention and the code itself is 666
meaning if you want to unlock the door
it's 666. someone comes upon that paper
and they say I don't know the
orientation of the paper
it may be nine it may be six the answer
is I don't know not that it's not
because I choose it to be because then
if you go to the keep at Terminal type
999 doorway you're applying relativism
if there's no nothing to relate it to
you you just have to take it but but in
in objective reality there are things to
relate it to and to grounded in so I'll
use Tim's example there's the adhesive
line on the sticky so that could give
you some evidence of which way it is now
let's say the adhesive rubbed off well
you're gonna have to look and see is
there a little hint of that adhesive
left or maybe it got ripped off unless
the intention of the individual was to
make an obscure symbol to confuse people
the it is either a six or a nine I think
our inability to understand the intent
of the person who who crafted that
symbol does not negate what the symbol
sometimes in nature there is no intent
it just is and and the experience of
being human is uh is our attempt to
rationalize there's always intent there
is well and always purpose and tea loss
and and and and let's let's take it one
step further again if this symbol
appeared on a tree because a lightning
lightning struck it and then it was
sideways and someone came up and said is
it a six a nine an e well I think it's a
six well I think it's a nine the reality
is it's a mark from a lightning strike
it's all three of those it's not it's
not it surely is yes in order for it to
be the symbol you describe it as it must
relate to the language the abstract
ideological structure of the person
ascribed it to if a fish flops on the
ground and draws this symbol I'm not
going to say that fish just wrote a
number for me I'm gonna say the fish
flopped the ground kinda looks like a
six kind of looks like a nine but you're
establishing a lot of things relative
aspects to the the the position like if
if someone walks into nature and that is
just on the ground it depends on what if
you come at it from one side it looks
like a nine if you're coming from that
it looks like a six well what what
you're really getting at here is is a
distinction between the way actually
that the left and the right view of the
world which is as one of a world of
interpretation or a world of activism in
the imposition of will so the idea of
law actually the idea of whether that's
a six or a nine the conservatives would
look at that and say look there is
objective reality there is an
intelligibility to the universe I have a
faculty of reason and so I can interpret
and I can learn things from the world
whereas the way that the modern left the
very relativistic self-centered left and
very willful wrathful left would look at
that and say I don't give a damn what
it's supposed to mean I'm going to deny
my faculties of reason I'm going to
pretend that men are actually women I'm
gonna say that babies aren't really
babies and it's going to be whatever the
hell I wanted let me pull this into this
analogy the right takes the approach I
think that you and I described Michael
where you'll see the symbol and they'll
say how did the symbol come to be and
what meaning does it intend to convey
the symbol exists I would like to
understand why it exists the left's
perspective is there's a symbol I'm
going to tell you what I want it to be
but it's a Humpty Dumpty right words can
mean whatever I want them but whatever
empowers me which is what political
correctness is to the right using
rationality I I think that is a good
method towards describing meaning but no
no to interpreting me to interpreting
not describing meaning but to interpret
it and so you incredibly rational
brilliant probably stop it Jesus level
IQ was certain that was a nine after a
moment of examining the situation using
your rationality that was one of the few
times that I've been wrong
the most brilliant no rationalists can't
be wrong yes and being wrong does not
mean it is wrong the thing is though you
weren't wrong you were right that wasn't
trying to make me feel better I was
wrong man you were right and you were
right and I was right no it was six or
nine and of scratch on paper it actually
isn't Ian you took a piece of paper with
the margin the top and you wrote a six
well I drew that shape I wanted to see
what number he thought it was I thought
it was a six so the point is the I think
in the culture where this is actually a
great conversation for people who are
listening this is I think it's important
to understand the left's predominant
view versus what we would describe as
the right the right includes post
liberals because the political factions
are no longer about policy it's now
about in understanding reality and I
grew up traditionally liberal uh I think
you did too right Michael oh yeah I'm
from New York I mean everybody was now
you're now you're uh theistic Christian
conservative yeah I don't know what I am
some kind of ism you know but I mean I
get I grew up I was always kind of a
young Republican type you know I had a
little liberal phase but to your point
Tim even being a young Republican
conservative type
but pretty much meant we were all
liberals for much of the last 30 years
so so I I like this this analogy this
this way to break down the the
way people see the world and when I see
the symbol I look for the evidence the
way you drew this Ian on this paper with
the paper's margin on top is how you
would typically make a six therefore you
drew a six you can call whatever you
want I understand for this purpose you
are not intending to make it either
symbol the left does two things the
first they jump to conclusions and then
insist they know because of ego
when they see the piece of paper they
will say it's whatever they want it to
be a nine or a six whatever suits their
needs at the time
they are unwilling typically to listen
to any evidence the typical leftist
perspective on this would be hey look at
that margin on top that means the six
well if that's offending their ego
because they determine to be a nine
they'll say you are wrong and they'll
make a similar argument to you which is
called sophistry an attempt to make a
fallacious argument to prove them right
for the sake of their dominance over you
because they believe there's no truth
but I don't think it is I'm pointing out
that it's it's both a six and a nine
that's not sophistry that's just an
observation right right and what I'm
what I'm explaining to you is
on a piece of paper with this
orientation you have drawn a six I mean
that's not what Michael told me 10
minutes Michael because I was wrong but
but you said you were okay but well now
you're wrong
I'm just going to be clear this is this
is this is my point yeah you actually
didn't you actually drew a six I mean
that's an upside down nine man flip it
upside down it's actually not it's an
ugly looking nine but it sure is you
drew this from that's how I draw you
that's not how you make nines I mean so
my point is simply this honestly I was
drawing a six yes you were thank you and
you're saying there is here I thought
you might think it was a nine yeah and
if I wished it was a square white piece
of paper with no more you succeeded at
deceiving me Ian but this this actually
this gets to exactly what was going on
last night at Pittsburgh by the way we
were supposed to have a debate and
conservatives are more inclined to have
debates and debates are about pursuing
logic to come to the truth and the libs
were outside throwing explosives and
that's and actually this gets back down
to the Bible you know there's an
important moment in the Bible when
Christ goes in and he's hanging out with
these two ladies Mary and Martha and one
of the sisters is sitting contemplating
what Christ is saying and the other
sister is serving the lunch and is busy
and doing all these things and what
Christ says is
the contemplative life is the better
portion not to say that we shouldn't
feed ourselves and you know we're living
in time and space we have to do certain
things to maintain our bodies but that
contemplation interpretation is actually
better than the act of life and we
obviously need both of these things but
we need if we're going to use our will
it has to be in accord with intellect
otherwise we're just going to start
throwing explosives at the wall you can
look at the way I wrote those letters to
determine what numbers they are it
96 B so what what I did was I flipped it
upside down and then I wrote a nine and
a six nines are not nines and six are
not drawn the same way the the when when
a person is taught to write they don't
draw nine by starting from the bottom
and then looping up on the top it's a
lot of top and then go down you're
making a lot of points based on like
modern culture and all that let me just
say this I think the point the danger in
all of this is what I'm saying is if you
become steadfast on what you think it is
and there is no other like I'm not
saying post-modernist okay but when you
claim something is what you think it is
it doesn't mean that it necessarily is
to other people that way but that's okay
you being that steadfast when you say it
is both a six and a nine you're
insisting upon that I'm trying to be
open-minded about it can be more than
one tyrannically open okay so here's the
you're not open-minded to my open-minded
here and and that's why I hate the
phrase open-minded it's meaningless yeah
you have to stop somewhere the point is
Ian
the right tends to have a view of there
is meaning let me figure out what it is
and if it turns out the symbol never had
the ascribed meaning then it's not a six
or a nine it was a shape I just want to
make sure people don't live their life
based on what they thought that symbol
was and just go all the way without
considering that they might be wrong
right and that's what the left does and
when you offend their ego they insist
they were right oh it's a big problem
it's a big problem among all sides and
groups of people that I can see but the
problem is if you have to open up a mind
then you become a post-modernist where
it could be anything thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time